[Music]
the jobs numbers are out so
i was a i'm aware of those numbers
because we had been talking about them
an hour or two ago actually off air
and then the guy calls in and he's
working part-time and he doesn't have
the money to fix an engine in his car
and he's got a 19 interest rate needs to
get rid of the car and all i can talk
about is get a job get a job get a job
and that's not because i'm a heartless
jerk
it's because
dude you can fall off a log you can get
a job right now
the jobs numbers are
i mean you can be dumber than a log and
get a job right now because the jobs
numbers are i've it's bizarre what's
happening out there
record numbers so the june labor
department report came out monday and
we've got 10 million plus jobs open
available right now in the united states
and you compare that to 8.7 million
people that are still unemployed many
choosing to be unemployed they're
they're still getting the federal
unemployment benefits that are set to
expire on labor day ironically enough
wait a minute wait a minute
the unemployment ends on labor day yeah
yeah so maybe it's time to start
planning to labor yeah yeah sometime
before then yeah and the opportunities
are endless dave
million plus jobs here's some good news
in this job report because you hear a
lot of doom and gloom
so the ramsay show is going to give you
the truth this is straight from the
labor department
if you look at the jobs
227
000 professional and business services
jobs
opened up in the month of june now
that's your white collar i think
corporate jobs this is really
encouraging 133 000
jobs in
retail that speaks to consumer
confidence that's a good sign and then
accommodation and food services that's
121 000 jobs added opened
right now
uh it's really unbelievable and and
here's the thing you and i were talking
about during the break you've got
companies like walmart mcdonald's
and target that have all announced in
the last 10 days
that they're offering tuition they will
pay for your college tuition
and these these are these are jobs that
dave are starting at 15 an hour it's not
this young man could go get employed
right now and not just make financial
progress but make some career progress
so 15 an hour
working 40 hours a week only yes just 40
which is really not working that hard
um
is 31 000 a year and free tuition yeah
can really jump start your life it's
better than eight hundred dollars a
month
a year without what he was making so
that was my point is there's 8.7 million
people unemployed there's 10 million
jobs
it sounds like we don't have any
unemployment it just sounds like we have
people not working it's exactly what it
is there's a difference and what a great
time to go get hired right now my
goodness employers will throw jobs at
you to your point earlier yeah i mean
we're in the process of hiring now we're
in a different league yes because of the
type of elite person we're looking for
at ramsey solutions but we're adding 300
positions this year and
we're getting a tons of
bazillions of applications yeah and uh
so
i mean if you can go work at walmart
make 15 bucks an hour work 40 hours and
go to school full time which you can do
by the way yes simultaneously uh go
through and get your degree don't tell
me you have to take out a student loan
and don't tell me you're starving to
death that's just ridiculous that's
exactly right and here's the deal those
dominoes are still beginning to fall
you're going to see a lot of other big
companies that are going to offer
tuition it's going to become a thing
sadly that people expect
but companies are in a position right
now where they've got to attract people
i mean this is literally when we've got
10 million jobs well what somebody said
you have to attract them not from other
companies you got to just attract them
off their couch that's the problem
because they're sitting there making
listen let me just talk to you if you're
sitting on your couch living off of
unemployment right now i'll just help
you with this okay it's not shaming
this is just factual life from papa dave
okay
there is no dignity
in your life when you are not
accomplishing something with your life
even if you are making a few dollars
more sitting on your couch then you
could be working you are not moving your
life your career your wealth building
the dignity of your relationships ahead
by sitting there even if you make more
is that well i'm not going back to work
i make less work well i mean not how
much less really but maybe you ought to
work more
so listen there is a
tremendous correlation between the
things that happen uh chemically inside
your body your mental health your
spiritual well-being the quality of your
relationships
not to mention the actual mathematics of
going to work that's exactly right you
could find yourself
theoretically getting ahead and i
wouldn't say by much but getting ahead
financially but
falling behind emotionally falling
behind spiritually falling behind
professionally look depression is a real
thing when you're not doing something
that you feel like i'm accomplishing
something that really starts to set in
and you've got to be very careful and i
think this is where we get into where
we've got government policy that is
disincentivizing people to get out and
to contribute well to become
what they were designed to yes that's
not designed to be a couch potato no you
were created to contribute to work
there's no question about that and and i
think you're absolutely right it's a
scenario how many of us i mean even if
you're doing something like even just
cutting the grass i'm not saying i'm not
saying for money i'm saying when you do
something that and you can look at the
the fruit of your labor yes and you feel
a sense of accomplishment there's all
kinds of things that happen
not only in society but inside of you
that are positive that do not happen
when you're sitting on your butt one of
my favorite things to do around the
house is pressure washing i get
tremendous joy out of seeing the before
and after and it feels really good to
sit back even though you know it may be
hot when you're doing you say look this
is better now because i actually applied
you know some basic diligence here to
hold a wand and
shoot water pressure at something you're
right there is a sense of accomplishment
accomplishment and there's things that
that changes the way you walk yeah it
changes your posture
it changes the way you relate to other
people it changes your ability and your
quality of your generosity yeah it
change i mean there's a there's a whole
soup of things here it's not as simple
as oh i'm beating the system
i don't have to work and the
government's going to take care of me i
and listen if you if you're down on your
luck i i get it i'm not mad at you i'm
not here to pick on you that's not the
thing
the the point is though that that
choosing and we've got these numbers
that are telling us that there's a large
number of americans they may not be
listeners to this show sure i'm probably
not attracted to this show probably but
but there's a large number of people
based on those numbers that could be
working and just are choosing not to
that's exactly right and when you're
working you're making progress whether
it's paying off debt or or funding your
way through getting qualified to do the
work you want to do you're going to have
to work at some point you're going to
have to and sitting at home right now
and here's the other thing this is not
going to stay this way
this is not going to stay this way
forever this is a great time to move to
actually get hired and i think of a
young person you think of somebody right
now going all right i went to college
or i never got the chance to go to
college couldn't afford it instead of
community college why don't you go work
for a big time company is going to pay
your way to get a degree they're going
to fund your future i don't know why you
wouldn't do that who cares if you don't
love stocking shelves i'm stocking
shelves for my future yep
yep it's perspective
it's just a great place to go when
you're broke to work